all right um welcome back to the core of
e logs sorry it took so long
hey he's been sick we've away no this
one's not uh no no no no if you've seen
the Man of Steel review that hand like
fucking music videos and animations and
crossovers so you can see the white
stuff in dizzy uh by the way back in
Rob's office and pretty much what we're
gonna do because most of you have seen
the last four and they ran like two of
them together than the last two online
like the same day or something like that
like we're just gonna do them all in one
bingo like the big finale here pretty
much uh what what's so funny is because
I watched these a while ago hmm
what happened before the finale you're
gonna hide just saw a ball like today so
Oh cuz I saw that hole I saw those two
episodes like the one hour long episode
like a while ago and then the finale is
also an hour long so I'm trying to
remember what I wasn't a funnel I just
saw them and I'm kind of trying to
remember what happened oh what happened
enough for now no no not the finale but
before it though uh no the big thing
that stands out about is that uh Boleyn
uh Kai saves the day which is nice it's
nice to see him getting you know he
fights against like the movies great
stuff and it's funny uh and it's what I
love the announcer oh now see what's
going on oh the price a little
microphone yeah so I okay now I know
yeah they're trying to kidnap the
president he kind of saves the day
uh what's you know I never really read
that budget to uh with Tom's daughter
being like you know oh it's Rob you come
on except when there's no security
around the president what the hell and
she's like what's going on here well
yeah you should that's cure I remember
the president I remember on my public
Facebook page writing that as much as I
loved a number of things that happened
in this episode there is some serious
what the hell yeah I got like I like
there were so many things I really
enjoyed like in particularly like Boleyn
helping to save the day I
really like that I liked if I remember
correctly what they were doing with
Korra I but Lin beifong what it did
it's almost like this was written by a
set of writers that had not really fully
watched season one yeah and then when
they say like you know uh well my code
called it along and she's like yes he's
a real hero I'm like boy that's good
junko and I'm like what I'm like are you
and you know the fact that I couldn't
even call the other cops crooked cops
they were just in company yeah she's
like well we have two new openings for
detectives like should be three a dumb
little it's like you you should feel
like you should be ashamed of yourself
and like she should I should I put my co
and I get it I know it happened end of
season one Amon also took her confidence
he fuckin been fitter dummy they got
Affairs like yeah I know but that a
stupid but we've been bitching and
moaning about Bad's I mean but that's
what happens in that but it was annoying
cuz she really was a major character I
mean think about all she did in season
one now she's just the chief he's going
to paw this time this is not a small
player this was a major character that
quite frankly I just feel the writers
have no clue what to do it I find it
actually insulting what they've been
doing with Lin beifong like is she was
such a great character moreso value than
corn because at least Coors redeemed
herself and all we get in here is a good
job I knew you had a know along and I'm
like really
yeah like I just wanted to literally
rewind to the point where she's like
yeah you just gotta be there are logs
I'll put my grandad you're gonna be a
beat cop and nothing more by the way I
want to be detected by we have two new
openings these cops are they trusted
like cold-heartedly like word for word
trust yeah so great moments in that
episode but some of the laziest
sloppiest writing I have ever seen in
this series to date so okay so that's
essentially that up this I know more
happens like I so we're trying to wrap
up fast um and then when we got the
episode after that we have
Tarlac 2.0 is
now gonna try and bring a tea pointin
yeah did bring the evil uh yang spirit
back and course to hold an Torian spirit
you know they're gonna try and go and
fight one other end uh and just sort
setting up the next episode I'd already
the only way to make tarrlok interesting
the writers finally figured it out
heaven possessed by more interesting
belches oh well that's one way to do it
I guess I'll take it you got you got the
fight between you know him and the
brother which is not I there they had a
bad story but not much else honestly and
that was another moment where I'm just
like yeah that was another writing
moment arm it's like oh yeah remember
these people yeah remember her I'm like
he comes back just to get his ass kicked
like what um at the very least we know a
little bit more
tarek 2.0 z-- plan uh which makes a bit
more sense I guess it's just sort of a
power-hungry thing but I mean again it's
just sir like okay you know it's the
witch about the Fire Nation came again
it's the mark hamill bad guy to just
rule the world all of it okay it worked
one too much sort of an interesting you
know idea going back the darkness and
stuff and him being merged with it's
like it's well more interesting that was
before it let's be fair I think again I
been a while I think if I remember right
it was more I think he's more of a
spirit sympathizer um yeah and that
there like it's not just that he wants
power I think he really has fallen on
the side of the spirits to a point that
he's become a zealot like somebody who's
like no spirits the spirits that we
should give it back to the spirits and
is convinced of uh
Klaatu Barada nikto so uh you know
vaatu's uh cause but but he's okay when
you say ten thousand years of darkness
come on you kind of know art this guy
might screw things a bit this might be
evil but and the spirits got to come and
you know and i'm gonna be is
avatar cool you know that's a nice perk
money okay let me plead you this way I
don't see it so much as a total power
grab as someone who's drunk the kool-aid
okay I know what I'm saying it's there
is a difference
yeah so they cuz I don't want that I
wish had done more of that but yeah they
they made it more interesting than what
it was before it was an okay make space
he's still not interested yeah he's
still aboard um and like I said bad
episodes just setting that up I do love
that artist formerly known as John
Hughes even in prison even when he's
just got into bed a very even way Sam
selves a bad guy is still so much fun
he's telling of course this is my prison
I have this cell set up just in case
I'll throw in me I had a feeling I get
thrown in here I mean it's been the damn
moment was absolutely brilliant in the
fact that Julie is in there with you
yeah I mean like what the hell did she
nothing he just needs an assistant yeah
it makes the barrack yes I like the
artist formerly known as John boos John
Hughes Howard Hughes as you learn from
me any longer nothing going names cells
on the plane don't worry uh so so that
that was good I mean I I like that
although as I point out he kind of
disappeared
well that's my friend Janice that's
another and particularly I also have
issues with the finale but the the
previous episodes particularly had so
many really great solid moments and I
like I want to cheer and I'm like really
into it and then we'll do things so
random like that was one of them I was
like oh that scene is really cool where
he's in prison and now he springs into
action like or something happens and I'm
like nothing so I'm like we shed that
whole season good cookie oh yeah next
season good could be next season okay
but I'm sorry that's cheap
I hear when comic-book movies do that
where it's like aha we hinted at him in
this season there were a buildup think
he really is gonna play a big part in
the next season but it didn't bother me
that much honestly this is just cuz he
was such a more interesting villain if
we can even call me calm about yes but
you're such an interesting Kaos
character that to see him to see that
whole thing resolved with and that was
it's like aha I'm gonna kidnap the
president know that plans gonna go right
Bolin saves the day which is cool but
then Varrick is put in prison what is
the point of all that like what did this
serve for the prep Iook what I just like
very sure I know I don't you know what
I'm I like that like he doesn't even
know if he's a bad guy he doesn't care
he's just into the new and the now and
let's go and I just I love he doesn't
care he used to really hate that he was
a villain but now it's like I really
like but see here's my problem
I love Varrick he actually is the best
villain in the show for me and you know
in season two but that's only one piece
of the puzzle you have to have a plot
with it no I mean anything else is nice
everything else is serving the cliches
they have to have in the show that they
feel they have to have with the cops you
know and you've gone too far but you in
jail and then you know nobody believed
me it didn't lead anywhere except for
okay well one thing's the day that's
cool but that happens in the finale as
well so it doesn't lead anywhere except
he hands them a battleship which there
was an there's no other way you could
have written that in somehow for them to
get a battleship and mock Oh basically
we find out that Marco knows what he's
talking about which was a shitty funny
yeah it's say going to plot points that
aren't really needed yeah you know but
all right so that that's those two
episodes and then we got the finale
which we should just treat us one we got
Tenzin and his siblings going into the
spirit world to find his daughter to put
in this prison was sort of mind prison
uh brilliant cameo with a general shout
their eye that was granted I like Lily
just like applauded when I saw that yeah
why should I like like that's and
there's a straight bar me that actually
liked that he didn't die I don't know
why but it's like no we're gonna give a
little bit more of a story to this to
what happens to this guy because he was
such a big character not all my personal
favorites but I still like seeing that
they he it's a real good ending for that
care it's kind of a punishment fits the
crime
yeah
what he was trying to do to the spirits
and the balance of the universe at the
end of season one you know yeah and I
love the idea of that prison such a
wonderful idea arms very the others that
fog that's yeah yeah I like that and I
for the most part I like the way tension
gets out of it though it's are we just
assuming that Aang literally came in and
helped him out there or is it that he's
mentally I don't know I guess it's part
of the fun you don't know I kind of it
is Tenzin's own self as Aang you know
projecting itself as Aang was telling
him yeah so it's like it's but in that
environment that that'd be tough to I
don't know so it open for interpretation
then hold on that whole scene was Berean
we got to see IRA again yeah I wrote
again we see the other IRA later but
yeah yes I'm a bit part shots fire yeah
I would I would like more with him but
that made it was gonna be more I don't
know well we had to watch ma Co try to
solve a case that nobody you've gone to
Bob oh um okay I can you know it all up
okay but we're just gonna keep harping
on that but okay so we got um a car goes
to the spirit world and tonic 2.0 fuses
with the yang spirit I'm gonna call
nothing by its real name ah
and it pretty much takes the spirit
Alcor out which the shit out of it and
hit the shit out of her connections to
it a smell yeah which is a pretty brutal
see Debbie you are so watch like oh oh
like it was Johnny Five
I mean it was a needed brutal scene uh
and of course and now this thousand
years of tartan thousand years of
darkness spreads across the world and
dogs and cats living together
is Oreo so you got the bad sphere goes
and he's just this giant Godzilla
monster now like ripping apart the angst
and that's racer and um and then Cora
goes into the treat memories I think as
well as cold and it's it Chris over the
world tree the the fountain you know
where if you need hugh jackman danger
sex foliage shit nice um and goes in
there and I like the idea behind it I
like that I like her going out well
although I get kind but we had before
what am i without my powers are whip I
hear it what am i without my identity
and this was I was a saint upfront I my
personal theory this is the apology for
the ending to season one um Matt and I I
try to think that I give them credit for
it I do I still have issues all together
how this is working as a whole but I'm
like no ok well at least when you did it
this time you know it feels right and
it's a good lesson because I think you
see so many people fall into this trap I
want to be the next this or I want be
this because this person did that and
there's this idea it's like it but these
people did because that was their own
and it's a concurrent lesson that both
she and Tenzin learn and while we're on
that subject yeah the best hands down
scene for me and it's it's just a
throwaway scene of you just kind of
watching it but it's that scene where
Tenzin and Cora are strategizing they're
you know they've just gotten beat up the
ten thousand years of darkness is
starting it's like what do we do you
know in Tenzin's throwing out Diaz she's
throwing that they're working together
and like it was such a great moment to
just finally see that I'm like - damn
seasons that we finally got their words
is like it feels like a spiritual leader
and his students their teaching and
their
yeah they're both teaching each other
things and the way they strategize was
as friends so like it's like we have to
do this together why do we have to wait
so why and why do we have to go through
these really force moments to get this
when we didn't need those force much
just about yeah okay so okay well
against Iran so help we're still just
doing the research what might happen
okay so or as in - yeah so uh so goes in
and course or finds her you know her
original inner spirit which is you know
good my only hang-up is that I think
happened way too fast when she started
it again something call the spirit or
any stuff I just like - she's got it
Aang forever to figure out how to do
things and he needed a guru and it takes
Korra for two seasons we're gonna to do
things but Tenzin just says hey you
should commit to your inner spiritual so
yo let only thing the only thing I can
figure the only excuse I can kind of
make for it is jumpin up quickly well
and what no Bakura can go into the
avatar avatar state very quickly that it
is possible some people can just have
this connector just born with that
connection could go in I mean that's the
thing she can go in and out or the
spirit world very quickly even though
she herself is a hothead but and that's
our favorite mo I give it a barely pay
yeah no see that's the thing is I have
really had me scratching ya know it to
me it's more like I mean you sort of
think this that well hey isn't someone
who's very spiritual can connect with
the spirit world and energy and so
should they be very calm and very
relaxed or very in control and she often
times it does not seem in control so
that's why the only thing I can figure
to possibly make an excuse for it is
that there are some people I think we
know people like this to who can have
like what who can have like
connections to something spiritual or
something otherworldly and stuff like
that but they're not always in control
either so that yesterday we can argue
that some people just get it or stumble
just I have it I get that it's but I
haven't seen a lot of that in her
character and most part it's just she
doesn't get it and then all of a sudden
she kind of does but I mean if you want
to argue that it's a weak argued along
setting it is
they barely pass I think what I needed
was in my perfect world probably kind of
what was happening with the episode
beginnings either rehash that or do some
of that there where she has a vision or
there's a struggle or she has to figure
it out yeah it's not an interest out of
Germany out of time and out of place
like in her own head like you could
argue that doing this in meditation is
its own timeframe so she can come back
out of it yeah uh but sort of journey
it's just she's so like yeah all right I
got a song gosh yeah mom I understand um
so she goes becomes Pacific Rim Cora
they don't fire Cora then they go fight
do some fun WWE stuff is you like pick
some up does this guy I want I want to
have I could share but it's cool it's
pretty cool um then the little intensest
daughter comes in I'm assuming because
at first I thought I was like Harry
Potter like I'm pointing my wand as far
as I can it's like I'm coming to glow
and that saves everything but is she
showing where the where her spirit is
inside is that what she's named believe
the idea is good I didn't think about
this hard and then I was talking I was
talking to it with my wife and then we
were like discussing it and then she was
offering her own theories and I believe
the idea is that remember Rama can't be
killed
yeah so she never can side him yeah
basically she's just been swallow this
is pathetic little speck of light but
can't be destroyed which is yin-yang
Adana Coromant order yeah so I believe
Jinora is basically going in and pulling
raava out no I think core core goes and
pulls her out but she comes in and glows
and then starts to glow inside so yeah
she's a minor yeah Jinora is like a
guide which is cool I like that whole
idea I don't think it was explained very
well but yeah buddy idea uh-uh
it out if that is fine you can argue
that if we have to talk and discuss it
but come to some sort of conclusion that
maybe that's a good thing is it's always
interesting um so yeah that that I
thought was actually really really cool
and then yeah good goes saves her
darling 2.0 is dead the the two siblings
kind of I don't know if it's really
charming or really a flaw that they keep
going back and forth between their
motivations the two twins you know and
then the romance with bowling can go
back and forth but again it's like is is
this really smart writing or
phenomenally lazy I can't I can tell her
that's smart because they're ironic
characters or if it's lazy because no we
were supposed to take it seriously it's
like if I don't take it seriously I
think it's hilarious and ology if I'm
supposed to take those physics ways -
yeah then it's really lazy writing yeah
it's giving writers the benefit of the
doubt and say we're not supposed to take
him that serious yeah so uh so Cora once
again brings balance bag that ten
thousand years whatever it goes back
into its hole and Cora what I thought
and here's what I'm like okay this this
is okay like this that this has come out
okay is she's about to close the portal
says what if I don't stick to the
friggin status quo that so many shows
especially kid shows like to stick to
and well if I leave this open
and what if hard times are coming it's
gonna suck but you know what it's worth
it for the good of the oh yeah yeah I'm
gonna leave the spirit world open and
yes yeah hallelujah the writers had a
great idea and and and she said and she
makes it a little speech at the end it's
gonna be tough is gonna be difficult but
it's worth the change we got it we got
to get through it this is evolving this
is going to the next step and it cuts
there and I hear the next season is
going to be called change and I'm really
looking forward to that season uh I'm
really looking forward to it too I just
hope they get their act together
yeah so I did this whole finale for me
what the last two episodes one talking
about specifically for me was it was
satisfactory which is I don't mean that
necessarily as an insult because I
didn't know how this finale
I turn out because it's been such a
rocky season uh and when I saw it I said
okay this was good I liked what it
amounted to um I didn't love it I don't
sound like a pure critic I like to have
to move it but the only reason I say
that is because you got these big giant
spirits fighting each other and I'm
thinking this shouldn't be gigantic an
epic and it kind of is something might
also missing kind of lame it I think for
show has done so much
I don't mind it going this route cuz
it's like it's faux fur good world and
stuff like that but what I realize
watching what I realized was missing I
know it so it's like don't draw
comparisons to avatar though a reason
I'm doing is because II I'm just saying
this is something that happens to be a
two and it was done right is that in the
finale of Avatar you got eggs battling
the the Phoenix King whatever and it's
one balance really building up to it
it's this one battle going on and he
fears out what he has to do and you know
applies it um and meanwhile books are
stuff going on in the background to it
that's careful been here we're in Seoul
which helps cuz it's working on multiple
levels and and here you have rather than
having Cora doing this one battle uh
whether in the spirit world or in the
city or whatever uh and realizing
something and finally coming to grips
with it it's there's about four or five
different battles going on different
variations she's one she's defeated
she's won she's defeated and when
finally gets that big one you know at
the end it's sort of like boy I wish I
could like I was just this was there one
of these fights was it uh because then I
can't rally around it as much why keeps
changing location now here's another
lesson now here's another thing we've
learned now here's another moment where
she's fail and now she's coming back and
stuff uh especially with Cora cuz I
really feel like if you want to sum up
the show in like five seconds it'd be
like her saying I'm the avatar I'm
stuffing strong I don't need anybody oh
no I screwed up everything I need
somebody I'm somebody help me okay now
I'm strong again
I've learned my lesson and if there's if
there's if there's another time I have
to see a fool that's you go oh but mmm
it's I just seen it so much well this is
part of it okay this is part of the
problem I think you're dancing around it
another reason the finale to last
airbender worked is you had a set of
characters that you have really got to
know and really really like like you
know every character in and out and
there was a progression and they didn't
deviate from their characters to a point
where it took you out of the story like
why are we doing this or why have we not
seen this character forever why it's
just better written and when you are so
close to those characters that are able
to make that connection it makes a
finale like that so much more important
and meaningful this really works and I
did love this finale because we're
finally at the point where I've made
that connection but I don't have two
seasons previous where that was done
perfectly um in my opinion overall I
think season one did it better and there
were chunks of season two that touched
upon it but not until right near the end
so it's like we've been sitting here
complaining about these things because
the characters have been inconsistent
all over the map you know basically just
kind of just bad writing um you know but
when you have characters that are
strongly written you have a progression
and it feels natural the caroler
characters feel organic like they're not
doing something out of character you
know it makes the payoff so much more
better the only thing I can figure is
that maybe because the side characters
in this season were so strong and so
entertaining that maybe they got too
distracted by them maybe the fact that
still had to be a 13-episode season it
maybe they just felt they had to squeeze
in too much stuff when really they could
just cut through stuff here's the weird
thing though the side characters were
really awesome and really entertaining I
totally give you that I love them they
were also entirely pointless exactly is
so you're not focused on your main plot
yeah I'm Eric who is awesome but it
built up to
nothing how awesome would it have been
honestly if what you got that bit where
Boland is you know talking with his
paternal touch I love that term now um
you know and and he has to kind of win
her over and he's kind of honest with it
and it's it's done for laughs but at the
same time I think of myself what if this
was kind of done seriously what if this
actually was what like the same way that
Toph and sockets that they were going to
fight the you know those giant blends
and stuff like that I was so invested in
that what if they did something like
that with these other two characters and
I really got invested and they just sort
of laid for Laughs you know why not like
you said bring the side characters more
into a crucial part of the story and not
just sort of this side filler that's not
really needed um so yeah I guess I I
liked this finale and I like that it did
sort of come back and it was doing new
stuff and it was big again it felt big
oh yeah my my only two grabs we talking
about the the speed at which she picks
it up um which to me was way more deus
ex machina in a way then really having
the tree there any of these other things
that you know the craters like to just
drop in um but cuz then one just didn't
make any sense of like oh you can argue
there's just a tree there or whatever
but I was like the way she picked up I
was like I just can't get that um I
think the second thing is I read the
writers explanation for what happens you
know basically she connects with her
sort of inner cosmic spiritual self and
I love the idea I really really like the
idea I there's something off about the
execution and I think that's because I
thought that it was kind of like a
metaphor and yet when you have giant
blue version of Korra fighting vaatu
Pacific Rim style it ceases to be a
metaphor and I'm just like this just
kind of looks like Pacific Rim or a
monster movie in it I'm not saying it
jump the shark but I watched it and I
was like yeah
it's cool they're fighting but it just
felt kind of Bob it was like this is
almost silly to me like is I mean I'd be
alive I didn't see what you're talking
about but at the same time I need
something big and we were demanding
something big and I know what you're
saying is that big doesn't necessarily
have to mean literally huge and overall
as yours are as it was because it was my
first I was like wow this is bizarre um
it's a minor gripe I actually like
probably go this is probably my favorite
episode since beginnings um and overall
I think it's really really really really
strong and does what the ending to
season one which for me was pretty good
up until last five minutes where it was
a total compound and so at least they've
learned their lesson and is like okay we
get it we're gonna do this right this
time core is going to have a big epic
battle she's going to fight but there's
going to be sacrifice and loss she will
lose something and have to deal with it
so I couldn't be more happy about that
it's um I got to say it's kind of like
Hunger Games too but we'll get to them
when we get to that depending on Wendy's
toe out as I start making up for
mistakes in the first um so yeah the
only other thing I'll talk about before
we do our quick wrap-up at the end here
is uh you got this love triangle thing
going on that I was happy didn't
interfere as much and I'm actually I
actually like how it ended
oh my god no no but at the same time
what was the point when she says the
line we should break up for real this
time I go you know if you have to say
for real this time
that's not a good sign um and I like how
it resolved itself but it shouldn't have
it's like if you feel you have to do it
cuz the writers for whatever really say
they love love triangles and just I
don't they didn't write in everyone
yes so if you gotta do it you know just
one time through don't have a comeback
don't have it whip through in all this
stuff you know just if honestly if you
took at the love triangle in the first
season and then head and just have what
happened and this one happened I
actually would have been okay
well in this X we already did in the
first season this is the biggest thing
about the show like because we're
talking about we're gonna wrap up two
seasons into it now like for me this
finale to season two felt like an
awesome great happy ending to what has
been a really bad road trend like it's
like you've been on this bumpy s road
trip annoy your family's getting on your
nerves it's like this is hell and then
all of a sudden you're at Walley world
and you have a greatest day of your life
so it's like was it worth it well it
ended really well so I guess now I got
it well - yeah well okay it started well
but all road trips start well you're a
few hours I'd be awesome and then five
days later with Clark W Griswald you're
like go to hell
so season one was the opposite that to
me was like a really great awesome road
trip but then while I want journalists
and then Waterworld his clothes on yeah
Waterworld being closing at via but
Walley world is closed so I was like
well I had a really great time but that
was such a disappointing ending so which
is better or worse I don't really know
what what bothers me is when you put
these two seasons together they don't
mesh up in the more and more I'm looking
at its season one is B is becoming
unless they try to tie it all together
in the next two seasons season one is
becoming more and more pointless by the
minute yeah I was going to say and I
love season one this is not saying I
don't like season one but the
ramification season one had none of it
carried over it's almost like season two
has been a sort of reboot yeah I mean
right down to the ending yeah even down
to we're gonna take this we're segue
into another season and it's pretty
yes that we are but not that annoying
way like you know I don't know there's a
Loki on the throne something like that
like you know I don't know it's that
this is you know it could end here they
wanted but the possibilities are so good
and they are off you can tie it in and
I'm sure will be interesting um so yeah
for me I think it started off good it
ended good I didn't quite hate the
middle as much but it it was annoying it
that rockiness especially what they do
Accords character just got so
frustrating and so many of the
diversions um
but you was still a lot of the
diversions were fun and I liked what
amounted to so it's it is really rocky
but I I'm just glad it came to a nice
conclusion and that it did finally give
some stuff that like yes I'm glad I saw
this I'm glad the gives the spirit world
and these tie-ins and stuff like that
I'm glad they after so long did finally
evolve a character and evolve the world
to which I like it I like where they're
going with this beard thing and what's
gonna happen with that so it's I'm just
glad they finally found its way and did
just lead down like a black hole or
really disappointing now and any missing
I really really really really love where
we are I love Korra as a character I
love Tenzin
I love Bolin ma Co all of these
characters now have come into their own
and I am totally willing to spend two
more seasons with them I have a much
better idea of who they are
well if they don't say well but the
thing is why did it have to take so long
and why to get to this point that I
still up did we have to wander around in
circles for a whole season could I not
have done this in a more tightly written
straight chat way to get us to this but
the conclusion she comes to at the end
with the spirit world is a very mature
even challenging a conclusion because
this is a big change for the world and
it's not a little thing why yeah why did
the progression she had to go through be
a repeat of the first one instead of
really diving into what we kind of delve
into when she went to the spirit world
stuff like that just expand it out
really dive into this stuff and explore
it
because there is more to explore you
don't have to retread and make her you
know just nothing but a hot head that
learns nothing part of the answer is be
honest is Nickelodeon Nickelodeon you
know I did hear somewhere and this is
total Internet
here say you know I they put it on a
picture with quotes so I mean it must be
real but what what I've heard a few
times is that they were really afraid of
doing a corner show because they were
afraid that boys wouldn't like a show
where the girl is the main lead and
stuff oh my god okay not it to be fair
they are Nickelodeon they dealt a lot
with kids so I'm sure they they got the
numbers and they know the ranking and
stuff like that
ah but at the same time eight when they
showed the show all the boys didn't give
a crap they're like she kicks ass we
love this character uh and and be yeah
you got a service a really wrist ill
your Nickelodeon you can and have
changed this hey you know if they forget
that the first avatar had so many great
female characters yeah but but not the
lead so it's like nothing even though
you can do this and the lead was an
effeminate little boy yeah exactly
because that's your macho stereo yeah
exactly ed but but what I was getting to
it that is um it is see did that could
that possibly head translated into her
it's like we need more action see with
her because that's what's keeping our
boy audience is that she likes to beat
stuff up and everything's not okay and
that that's the only thing I can sort of
figure maybe with why they keep having
her go back to the same spot
no I here's what I think happened I mean
let's okay imagine your writers we're
gonna greenlight one season what about
after that yeah so your get throw it on
you're put into a situation let's throw
it all in there well how do we end this
thing well we can't terminate or to end
this thing with big and ambiguous
because if it just ends here people
we're gonna be like well with them Santa
spits I was it happy ending it like so
season one now you have a season two hey
we have season two and you're gonna need
to do two more seasons out of this well
now what I mean that's really pretty
much I disagree
I think you can no no no don't let me
finish okay I thought no let me finish
that's half the problem the other half
is now you have to really put on your
thinking cap as a writer and be like
okay well we did all this in season one
how do we continue this story and they
did they just were like I on season one
yeah I'll get behind they're backin
we're just gonna do this all over again
and start from sort of square one and
that's what really bothered me about the
seasons like there's no reason to go
back you know to square one with this
there's no reason for all the diversions
of running away any circle in another
element they do before with the idea of
the spirit but you're right the rest of
the story is just such a weight really
in it for like keep in mind like we're -
oh the spirits the spirits possess oats
to get there it was verax plod know what
I'm saying is that the idea to evolve it
like was there wasn't like an only trade
but it was that they spent so little
time on there not enough time I should
say you know and instead too much time
on what made the first one successful
one bets I don't think that's what a lot
of people wanted to see or at least not
what we wanted to see um I don't know
what made the first ones a oh you Last
Airbender or no uh Korra what made the
first season successful was it was a
tightly wound well paced different
different political thriller that went
from point A to point B I know you hated
the bending thing but it did connect to
the plot and quite frankly it still was
a part of it there was not a lot of
filler for me in there the villain who
originally takes her away ties into the
whole story at the end it helps give
away all the plot points at the end it
all wraps up in the neat tight bow and
yes the last five minutes of it sucked
but that's what made it successful and
that's what really has me scratching my
head is this one for such a great ending
and a couple of really great additions
to the mythology got everything else
wrong it's like this is a meandering
poorly paced everywhere fourteen
different stories going on once only
half of which even bother wrapping up
I'm thinking like if I could take like
if I could just die
just take like the opening engine for
Katya and then you know take like
beginnings okay little trimming here and
then that ending it's like we never
really solid quite frankly I could take
the things I liked in season one and
mesh it with season two and take up the
crappy ending of season one and yeah
somewhere they're very mush them
together this would be a really this
would be a perfect show yeah this would
be out there with avatar um but as is
you know again I I'm glad we can have
this discussion at all with a
Nickelodeon show and time again most
likely Vincent this is you for all those
problems is still hands above most
things out there yeah I mean animated or
live-action um and we complain really a
beauty gigabyte begging me Becky get
show that's all like I love your angry
voice somebody's angry pant I drink like
but it's like we complain because we
care no it sounds silly but because it
means like because we really like this
you know tear because we can and because
quite frankly they're doing really good
things this is still a step above the
rest and if we don't make it known that
yeah these things bother us and you can
do better they'll just be like what the
fuck like what you know saying we can't
make it repeat it like like the good
parts of this so so I mean I'm I say
these things because I think they do
really really good work and yeah there's
some missteps that I'm just saying hey
if you can improve on this than season
three is gonna be even better and yeah
still look much love much love Oh work
the vessel I want to get frogs I mean it
is so easy to say what we don't like and
how to fix things baby I think so many
people online can take that ass oh you
didn't like it no we is so much of what
a lot of Italian we wouldn't be able to
talk about this if we just didn't like
it there's nothing the dogs still
entertain even with the system to change
like they were entertaining
yeah and there's somewhere but they were
entertaining and there's so many smart
elements it's how well it's it's always
how can we utilize as much as we can out
of that um so yeah uh that's about it I
think we both sir I had the same thought
on season two you know very rocky ride
but start it ended well good you know
then it can't be are much better than we
thought he was going to at the latest
just with the rocky road it was going
there so um that's about it and we'll
see you at season 3 late